canada is stepping up its efforts to
train ukrainian soldiers extending
operation unifier by three years however
trainers on the ground now near contact
lines in the donbass region are being
pulled back minister you're moving
canadian forces west of the river what
information do you have that prompted
that change
the safety and security of
the armed forces is
my top priority
at all times
and out of an abundance of caution we
are
repositioning some of our troops
it's not known if canadian officials
have new information about a potential
russian threat in eastern ukraine the
ukrainian military has battled
russian-backed separatists there since
2014.
a ceasefire is in place but is often
violated including monday when a
ukrainian soldier was killed by an
anti-tank grenade russia has threatened
to take military action at the u.n
security council russia tried
unsuccessfully to block diplomatic
dialogue fellow members of the council
and other u.n member states we urge you
to assess not only russia's statements
but their actions with clear eyes
i have clear instructions
from my government
to reiterate today
the absence of any aggressive intention
as well as ukraine's strong commitment
to peace in the russian parliament there
will be a vote in two weeks over whether
to formally recognize areas within
ukraine's borders now controlled by
pro-russian groups as independent states
more destabilization says ukraine russia
could then use these regions to build up
military assets
russia's ambassador to the u.n blasted
the west for stoking fears of war the
discussions about a threat of war is
provocative in and of itself
you
are almost calling for this you want it
to happen you're waiting for it to
happen as if you want to make your words
become a reality
nato countries have clearly stated that
peace is their goal however preparations
are continuing for a conflict those
military trainers being relocated and
soon non-essential staff at the canadian
embassy will be leaving a move the
ukrainian president last week vocally
opposed saying his country is not the
titanic
donna
crystal command sing in keith tonight
thanks